it was a big night on TV as Kim
Kardashian dealt with the aftermath of
Kanye West's hospitalization I'm just
like emotionally just like drained and
exhausted and we said goodbye to our
favorite girls I would like to help you
raise your baby oh Jesus Christ
[Music]
it will be okay everything will be okay
two months after Kim Kardashian was
robbed at gunpoint in Paris the 36 year
old was confronted with more bad news
her husband Kanye West was hospitalized
for exhaustion Kim opened up about the
emotional experience and how it impacted
their family on Sundays Keeping Up with
the Kardashians can't imagine having
kids are doing all that yeah I'm crazy
and that's what's hard cuz like they
don't know anything you know I'm just
trying to be like normal at home for
them
Kanye was really cute he's like so this
is what for better for worse means and
then like yeah he's gonna be fine over
on the series finale of girls we got to
see Hannah in a completely new light as
a new mom to her son growver after six
seasons of hookups in the city hannah
has seemingly settled down raising her
kid in a rural area with help from her
mom and BFF Marni although she initially
struggles with motherhood I don't want
to say I don't know what I did to him
cuz I grow them in my body for nine
months but he hates me the final moments
of the beloved HBO series ended on an
optimistic note Hannah smiling as she
fed little Grover
you